[Music]
On June 5th several Arab countries broke
ties with Qatar well some say Russian
kakenews precipitated the crisis Qatar
and nasarah foes have been on a
collision course for some time what's
going on
Qatar is the world's richest country per
capita it floats on a sea of gas and is
more money than it knows what to do with
it slated to host the World Cup in 2022
and as one of the world's largest
airlines that's not bad for a country of
just over 2 million
the problem is cutters become the
primary bankroll or of the Muslim
Brotherhood this is annoyed countries
like Egypt in the UAE which excuse Qatar
funding groups which want to overthrow
their government
it supports Hamas in the Gaza Strip in
Bank folks turkeys ruling party to top
it all off cutters been reaching out to
Iran in effect Arab states say it's now
or never to stop what's becoming a new
axis of evil what does this mean for the
u.s. Qatar hosts the alidade air base
which the US has used since the 1990
Qatar saw that ISM source the US would
never do anything to endanger the base
the question is whether the goal
blunting Islamist finance Trump's the
need for the base on this Qatar may have
miscalculated very badly what do you
think about Qatar and what should the
United States position be if any let us
know in your comments and also let us
know what other topics you'd like a AEI
scholars cover in 60 seconds